so i've been doing the show for a while
now and it seems like a lot of people
have a lot of opinions about the way old
petey is dressed
i'm not joking i mean look at look at
some of the things my guests have said
check this out if you put my your shirt
with my pants yeah it would be like a
just a full eggplant
you're dressed like
like you're you're the ceo of a pumpkin
patch
it's hard now to go back and say yes you
do look nice now that i'm looking at you
yeah that happened
and those are my guests so what i need
is a helpful friendly loving effusive
gracious platonic female friend who
could come with me to help me pick out
some new clothes unfortunately i don't
have one of those
i have chelsea peretti
chelsea is a stand-up comedian and an
actor on fox's brooklyn nine-nine she's
sarcastic she's mean she's one of the
worst people in the world
and i absolutely love her to death
please watch this video what happened
when she went with me to pick out some
clothes in a segment we call my worst
best friend
so i have to decide what i'm gonna wear
for the show and i have to find some
looks do people call them
find some looks so i brought my worst
best friend uh chelsea peretti here to
help me i am known for my warm
personality this will be a real
friendship ender
what about this
that's great curious george get back
seriously this actually does duplicate
the vibe of your personality i'm a hot
mustard
exhausting
visually harsh
and also boring somehow
this is the coolest thing i've ever seen
in my life what is this an option this
is the best what is this oh gucci makes
it i couldn't tell i look like a
high-end bill cosby honestly and then
imagine this pant and it's actually the
length of your leg leo meet me up
versace i wanted to buy some high-end
sweater pants really come see your
father's three thousand dollar sweaters
this is a cool rack back here this this
is the mc hammer ramp
this is like theo cleo yeah dad get out
of my bedroom
i don't know we're running out of
options you missed this one
this is pretty dope
definitely
i look like chester cheetah's lawyer
it's not easy being cheesy he was under
a lot of stress is that a pre-written no
but i am like the best
i'm not gonna look at you
and i know that you're going to try to
work a terrible impression into this
moment which is y'all
i'm sorry i couldn't save you
two days
this is a great fit
this is definitely if you wanted to go
touch kids in any way
this would be a great way to let the
mothers know
we don't have anything and laugh just
like that
that's a great on your turquoise
i'm the sheriff of this damn the sheriff
has four asses
is that modeled after you did i already
asked that so to make sure that gets in
um pete seriously
thanks for having me rooting for you
love you
oh jk
that is the worst i know but i have to
go
bye chelsea thank you
she's the worst everybody